if you met someone would you say it with
chest and say I don't want kids I've
said it before and it's quite funny
actually because you mentioned that the
fact that um a lot of women would like
end up alone if they told someone that
they were not they didn't want children
in general I don't think that's true
because I have told people like if you
ask me oh do you really want because I'm
like no not really because every man on
here want kids yeah majority majority in
a very very small size like let's think
about you just said a small sample size
because you said the guy that I'm
curious
guys I'm curious guys off camera does
anyone not want children from the men
anyone
okay
I'm just curious does anyone not like do
doesn't want kids is anyone saying yes
majority no I don't think maybe I'm in
the morning and that's completely fine
I'm probably just trying to sleep with
these yeah
it is what it is that's completely fine
but like I just I don't know
um I feel like a lot of people have
children because they feel like they're
supposed to rather than because they
genuinely want how old did you say you
are again I'm 23. so one thing you did
say is that when you was 19 you you was
all over having kids no I didn't that's
not what I said I said I was more likely
to be persuaded into having one child
but as I've gotten older The more I've
learned the less I want children okay
kids for life so you've got to
understand that one exactly like even
when you're a 56 year old that is your
baby like no matter that's my life as
soon as you have a child your entire
life goes to the child whether you want
to or not and the thing is if I had a
child 100 I'll be [__] diverted to my
baby but do I want to be complete it's
just it's just interesting because like
when people list the reasons that they
don't want to have children you kind of
admitted this early on like it's why
they say modern women are selfish
because everything's about me me it's
like I don't want to give up my free
time I don't want to give up my job I
don't want to give up my mind
but there's a problem being selfish if
you're not selfish and you and you
choose to be naive and blindfolded and
act like you can do everything and you
do a half-hearted job
I I agree like I agree with what you
were saying about the nannies like I'm
not saying every single person should
have kids but usually the people that
don't have kids I would say are selfish
nah you have to be selfish you have to
be so well I genuinely disagree with
that I'm sorry that's really crazy being
selfish for a woman has a shelf life to
be honest
in a sense where like you can be selfish
up to a point but then you kind of gotta
make a decision in it like yeah
I couldn't have a kid with my life right
now I think which is understandable but
that doesn't mean like you still don't
have a shelf life on being selfish yeah
I don't know I need you to elaborate on
shelf life and being selfish okay as you
as you said earlier um like obviously
there's a certain time limit on
obviously when a woman can well possibly
not sorry yourself then maybe at a
certain time on having a child so
obviously you can be selfish up to a
point but then sooner or later you've
got to kind of make the decision whether
you obviously want a child or you don't
so that's I agree you know what yeah
I think if you if you've known from
young that I genuinely want children 100
if you want children to [__] have
your babies like I don't mind that and
you know I mean like if you want your
baby if you want 10 kids have 10 kids I
don't mind that at all in fact I want my
friends to have kids so I can be an
auntie you know I mean you're scared I
don't want to be pregnant yes I mean
of course I'm scared because you're
scared of no it's not because I'm scared
but also the responsibility that comes
with a child is so much for me I'm
barely functioning as a human being I do
not want to take care of another human
being as well and I'm not telling that's
fine I'm all about people doing what
they want to do I don't even think that
every single girl should have it there's
a lot of people that shouldn't have kids
no but I think the people that shouldn't
have kids are usually too selfish to
have children like you're just like you
know what some sort of scary thought
because you were talking about age
earlier yeah and you were saying what if
you're 55 and I'm thinking yeah I want
children but let's say I wouldn't want
children yet and at 55 I'm home with 80
cats because no one I'm sorry but it can
happen you know and then I'm like it
would have been nice to have someone
that and and at 55 you kind of switch to
like the men's perspective because
because yeah because you know they start
to treat you like they treat the men
because people aren't attracted to you
as much anymore I just want to take it
back to this point that you made about
if you don't want kids you're selfish I
actually genuinely disagree with that
because to me especially the points that
you guys have made for wanting kids is
like I want to carry on my legacy my
legacy you're talking about yourself
that's inherently selfish
I don't give a [__] I'm just gonna lie I
don't
now women don't care about their legs
why would it matter what Legacy matters
to you within a hundred years manager
you're going to be forgotten regardless
yeah but that's what my child is for
yeah but two generations down and
they're gonna keep having kids
remember you personally but I've heard
stories about my great-grandparents
right like I had a lot of
percentage from someone that was like
great lately they always make fun of me
in the comments
[Laughter]
I mean I just think the point is that
something like bigger than yourself like
I'm just thinking if I'm if I'm 65 and
by myself like one who's gonna take care
of you because someone's got to take
care of you in order
and and the second part is like like you
want to die alone but even even even
even better even by that logic though
what's the purpose of us doing anything
yeah
we're just gonna die cool we're gonna
die
I get what you're saying alone but by
that logic but by that logic there would
be no purpose for us to be doing
anything
do you want to settle down settle down
with a partner yeah yeah of course I do
just be able like that's the thing no
that's because wherever you settle down
with most likely the may not but most
likely they're gonna want kids
that's what whatever okay
it makes a difference it's not a man
then obviously completely I understand
that that's why I make it a good point
to be like hey if they bring up anything
to do with children or if the
conversation comes up I'm gonna be
straight up I feel like I'm not gonna
lie I'm not really interested if you're
trying to I don't like legit I'm gonna
get into that yeah
say it straight away I find it no no I
find it interesting to hear like what
people say or why they think the way
they think because I'm like okay I might
disagree but okay you might have points
that I just thought what point I was
making is that I mean I'm sure you as a
mother could say like that you have to
put the kid before you exactly the
situation like my kid comes first in
every situation I'm not like like I said
I want maternal and before no I shocked
my mom on my child's birthday every year
goes well done
all my friends and my family that never
expected it from me but I am like
self-proclaimed no I am I think I'm a
good mom definitely no one said any
difference to me but um like but I I
just never expected it one in the plan
but like it is my priority in every
situation in my life and it just changed
your life so much but if if you don't
want kids then that's fine I feel like
everyone's got different it's like
saying what do you want to do for a
living what is what's your career choice
what's your job if that's your dream
that everyone's just totally different
but girls feel the pressure and with the
thing where it was like something to do
with having kids and blah blah blah what
is what I was going to say before is for
men it is a legacy because what do you
do when you get married you take the
man's name then what do you do when you
have kids it takes the man's name it's
carrying on their name and they're like
they're honoring their dads and their
dads before them because you all take
their name and you pass it down and
that's what it is like we've just been
that's that's what it is for most people
if they don't see the dad's a lot of
people
[Music]
we're going to the birth certificate
like for me I think it's cool to have a
legacy like yeah if I get married and
have a kid obviously it won't have my
last name but then that's going to be my
last name do you know what I mean so
that's my legacy regardless I think
that's cool what were you gonna say I
just take the conversation back you just
this is for you
um if you were ever on a date with a
girl that you really really were into
really liked her she ticked all your
boxes but she had a deal breaker and
well she said she don't want kids you
don't want kids would you wait wait no
no you're saying
especially but I'm just asking you would
you look to persuade her would you try
do you think there's room for that do
you think that support there's a
possibility would I try to sway a woman
or like influence her too or would you
try to try to if you would like to if a
woman saying to me that she doesn't want
kids I'm not going to try and convince
her but listen recreational might be an
option
because obviously if let's just say you
know what because I said when the food
comes down say because that year is a
very big thing especially to men funny
to me that men talk about having
children it's so joking why is it jokes
because you man don't do any of the work
required talk about how do you talk
about protecting
and providing my ass
I mean the physical hard work required
to carry a child what's what's harder
giving birth or raising a child raising
it's both of them women
I'm not trying to be rude but like dogs
give birth
acting like this is so crazy look every
other species I'm not talking about the
given birth part yeah it's easy you
shouldn't say that though
because fair enough here you are right
we don't do the physical part but
there's other things that we have to
deal with we have to we have to do we
have to we have to do you like in
general like it's a very no I'm just
being real like obviously you're not
very lucky when you're pregnant it's
it's touchy it's touchy
and as well
it's hard be dealing with a woman that's
carrying a whole human being in her
stomach
I have I have a friend right now shout
out Ali love you
[Laughter]
I think more afterwards mentally
emotionally and mentally afterwards is
that that's the test that is a big big
test no matter how how about the story
pregnant people no matter how bad you
feel right now it will get worse
I love you but it's bad
you just your emotions are everywhere
your head's everywhere and nothing makes
sense it's
um it's a roller coaster I get I get
what you're saying like obviously
physically we're not pushing out the
baby but like what would you actually
want the man to do like what can we do
I'm not I'm not saying it's not your
fault that you don't carry a baby but
the way you said it was like
next door
can you clarify what you meant no I just
meant that you guys are like oh yeah of
course that I would want to have
children whatever whatever but it's like
I don't know how do you do to the night
feeds so you change nappies are you
there 24 7. if I need a break
I'm talking about night fees it's
physical it is physical she's
complicated
a lot of guys do it a lot of yeah
there's a lot of guys that do it but
there's a [__] lot at that door yeah
but this is what it looks this is why
you choose exactly when you get a child
100 you know how many people I've seen
here they have relationship issues and
then they think you know
baby and this baby yeah is is gonna get
born into this toxic relationship it's
gonna be the leverage it's gonna be like
but you acted up I'm taking the child
and you're and you're really minimizing
the guy's role though like like men have
to go to work every day and provide for
you like that what do you why are you
acting like that's nothing they have to
protect you if someone breaks into your
house like they're the ones that are in
charge they're the ones that have to
protect you you're not gonna go
downstairs
I think she's talking about the people
that don't do what are you talking about
so for me like when you said the the
protector and the reason I've always
been that person
what you said where you're all like you
you would choose someone that is going
to give you all the things I got
probably some things it didn't happen if
you had a choice
it needs to be you okay one at a time
one at a time one okay go ahead yeah no
I'm not complaining in any way and I'm
the first person to listen it was not
fandom blah blah blah but like because I
went through with that situation right
but you're saying like men men
why would you not choose someone that's
going to give you these things I got
told I weren't going to get them things
but I expected those things right just
didn't get there right but I'm saying it
but for me I just roll with it and then
I I'm not complaining yeah
I shouldn't expect it right do you think
like it probably would have been avoided
if you got married first because
yeah no difference to my situation
except from a [__] message of actions
though it would prove more than just him
saying
she needed a ring just to confirm that
he was he wasn't gonna be a man of his
word is that what we're saying is that
just a ring I mean I'm just being stupid
do you know how big of a risk marriage
is for men in 2022 okay
wait wait guys do you know how big of a
risk of marriage is for men in 2022 okay
we we leave 70 to 80 percent of the time
90 of their college educated you they
can lose up to 75 percent and take the
kids okay and give okay we're talking
about a man that didn't keep his word
we're not talking about whether sorry
the point that she's making is that um
what you should have waited until
marriage to say that he was promised
those things
because because because and I'm not like
it's your situation I don't know yet but
but the point is like if somebody does
something it's better than them saying
that they're going to do something like
I can say I can say I'm a millionaire
that doesn't make me more
like what you've said that you like all
right so if you'd have got married would
it be different no like for my situation
personally the reason like it would not
have made a difference if we were
married or not if if anything it would
have just made it there was nothing and
I was would have got gained from it
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible